The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Today is sort of
the culmination of everything
we've been doing in the
model free optimal control.
OK.
So we talked a lot about
the policy gradient methods.
So under the model
free category here.
And we've talked a lot about
model free policy gradient
methods.
And then the last
week or so, we spent
talking about model
free methods based
on learning value functions.
OK.
Now both of those have some
pros and some cons to them.
OK?
So the policy gradient
methods, what's
good about policy
gradient methods?
STUDENT: They scale--
RUSS TEDRAKE: They scale with--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK.
And they can scale well
to high dimensions.
We'll qualify that.
Right?
It's actually still only a local
search, that's why they scale.
And the performance of
the model free methods
degrades with the number
of policy parameters.
But if you have an
infinite dimensional system
with one parameter
you want to optimize,
then you're in pretty good shape
with a policy gradient method.
Right?
OK.
What else?
What are other pros and cons
of policy gradient methods?
What's a con?
Well, I said a lot of it
in the parentheses already.
But it's local.
What are some other cons
about policy gradient methods?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
Right.
So this performance
degradation typically
is summarized by
people saying they
tend to have high variance.
Right?
Variance in the
update, which can
lead to mean that you need
many trials to converge.
I mean, fundamentally, if
we're sampling policy space
and making some
stochastic update,
it might be that it
requires many, many samples,
for instance, to accurately
estimate the gradient.
And if we're making a
move after every sample,
then it might take
many, many trials for us
to find the minimum of that.
It's a noisy descent.
Yeah?
STUDENT: You also have to
choose like a [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
That wasn't even on my list.
But I totally agree.
OK.
I'll put it right up here.
There's one other very big
advantage to the policy
gradient algorithms.
We take advantage of smoothness.
They require smoothness to work.
That's both a pro
and a con, right?
But the big one that we
haven't said yet, I think,
is the convergence is sort
of virtually guaranteed.
You're doing a direct search.
And exactly, you're doing a
stochastic gradient descent
in exactly the parameters
you care about.
Convergence is sort of
trivial and guaranteed.
OK?
That turns out to be
probably one of the biggest
motivating reasons
for the community
to have put their efforts
into policy gradient.
Because if you look at the
value function methods,
in many cases--
now, I told you about one case
with function approximation,
still linear function
approximation,
where there are stronger
convergence results.
And that was the least
squares policy iteration.
But most of the cases we've
had, the convergence results
were fairly weak.
We told you that temporal
difference learning converges
if the policy remains fixed.
OK?
But if you're not
careful, if you
do temporal difference learning
with the policy changing,
with a function
approximator involved,
convergence is not guaranteed.
OK?
In fact, they often, I mean a
lot of these methods struggle
with convergence.
Not just the proofs,
which are more involved.
But there's a
handful of, I guess,
sort of in the big switch
from value methods to policy
gradient methods,
there are a number
of papers showing sort
of trivial examples of--
can I call them TD
control methods?
So temporal difference
learning where you're actually
also updating your policy
of TD control methods
with function approximation,
which diverge.
Right?
There was even one that--
I think it might
have been, I forget
whose-- it might have been
Lehman Baird's example.
But where they actually showed
that the method will actually
oscillate between the best
possible representation
of the value function and the
worst possible representation
of the value function.
And it's sort of stably
oscillated between the two.
Right?
Which was obviously something
that they cooked up.
But still, that makes the point.
Right?
Even the convergence result
we did give you for LSPI,
least squares policy
iteration, still
had no guarantee that
it wasn't going to,
it could certainly oscillate.
They gave a bound
on the oscillation.
But that bound has
to be interpreted.
Even the LSPI could
still oscillate.
And that's one of the stronger
convergence results we have.
OK.
But they're
relatively efficient.
Right?
So we put up with a lot of that.
And we keep trying to
use them because they're
efficient to learn in the
sense that you're just
learning a scalar value over
all your states and actions.
That's a relatively
compact thing to learn.
I told you, I tried
to argue last time
that it's easier than
learning a model even by just
dimensionality arguments.
And they tend to be
efficient because the TD
methods in particular
reuse your estimates.
And they tend to be
efficient in data.
They reuse old estimates.
They use your old
estimate of the value
function to update your new
estimate of the algorithms.
So when they do work,
they tend to learn faster.
And they can, with the
least squares methods,
they tend to be
efficient in data.
And therefore, in time.
Number of trials.
When these things do work,
they're the tool of choice.
The problem is-- and
there are great examples
of them working-- but
there's not enough guarantees
of them working.
And if you want to
sort of summarize
why these value methods
struggle and why
they can struggle to converge
and they even diverge,
you can sort of think of it
in a single line, I think.
The basic fundamental problem
with the value methods
is that a very small change
in your estimate of the value
function, if you
make a little change,
can cause a dramatic
change in your policy.
Right?
So let's say my value
functions tip this way.
Right?
And I change my
parameters a little bit.
Now it's tipped this way.
My policy just went from
going left to going right,
for instance.
And now you're trying to
update your value function
as the policy changed.
And just things can start
oscillating out of control.
Does that make sense?
OK.
That's a reasonably accurate,
I think, lay of the land
in the methods we've
told you about so far.
If you can find a value method
that converges nicely, use it.
It's going to be faster than
a policy gradient method.
It's more efficient
in reusing data.
You're learning a fairly
compact structure.
Value iteration has always been
our most efficient algorithm,
when it works.
But the policy
gradient algorithms
are guaranteed to work.
And they're fairly
simple to implement.
And they can just be sort of
local search in the policy
space.
Directly in the space that you
care about, really your policy.
So the big idea, which
is the culmination
of the methods we've talked
about in the model free stuff
so far, is to try to take
the advantages of both
by putting them together.
Represent both a value function
and a policy simultaneously.
There's extra
representational costs there.
But if you're willing to do
that and make slower changes
to the policy based on guesses
that are coming from the value
function, then you can
overcome a lot of the stability
problems of the value methods.
You get the strong convergence
results of the policy gradient.
And you get some of the
more, ideally, efficiency.
You can reduce your
variance of your update.
You make more effective updates
by using a value function.
OK?
So the actor is the playful
name for the policy.
And the critic is your
value estimate telling you
how well you're going to do.
And one of the
big ideas there is
you'd like it to be a
two time scale algorithm.
Policy is changing slower
than the greedy policy
from the value function.
OK.
So the idea is an actor critic
are actually very, very simple.
The proofs are ugly.
There's only a handful
of papers you've
got to look at if you
want to get into the dirt.
But these, I think,
are the algorithms
of choice today for a
model free optimization.
OK.
So just to give you a couple
of the key papers here.
So Konda and Tsitsiklis.
John's right upstairs.
Had an actor critic
paper in 2003
that has all the algorithm
derivation and proofs.
Sutton has a similar one in '99
that's called Policy Gradient.
But it's actually
the same sort of math
as in Konda and Tsitsiklis.
And then our friend Jan Peters
has got a newer take on it.
He calls it Natural
Actor Critic,
which is a popular one today.
It should be easy to find.
OK.
So I want to give
you the basic tools.
And then instead of
getting into all the math,
I'll give you a case
study, which was my thesis.
Works out.
So probably John already said
quickly what the big idea was.
Right?
So John told you about the
reinforced type algorithms
and the weight perturbation.
In the reinforced algorithms,
we have some parameter vector.
Let's call it alpha.
And I'm going to change alpha
with a very simple update rule.
In the simple case, maybe
I'll run my system twice.
I'll run it once with the--
I'll get once, I'll sample
the output with alpha.
And then once I'll do it
with alpha plus some noise.
Let's say I'll run it from
the same initial condition.
Compare those two.
And then multiply the difference
times the noise I added.
Right?
And that's actually
a good estimator,
a reasonable estimator
of the gradient.
And if I multiply by
the learning rate,
then I've got a gradient
descent type update.
OK?
So this is not useful
in its current form.
John told you about the
better forms of it, too.
But the problem
with this is that I
have to run the system
twice from exactly
the same initial conditions.
You don't want to run two trials
to simulate the thing exactly
twice for every one update.
And it sort of assumes that
this is a deterministic update.
The more general form here
would be to not keep, not
run the system twice.
But use, for instance,
some estimate
of what reward I'd expect to
get from this initial condition.
And compare that to
the learning trial.
So we just went from policy
gradient to actor critic
just like that.
This is the simplest form of it.
But let's think about
what just happened.
So if I do have an estimate
of my value function,
I have an estimate of my
cost to go from every state.
Right?
Then that helps me make
a policy gradient update.
Because if I run a single trial,
then I can compare the reward
I expected to get
with the reward
I actually got very compactly.
OK?
So this is the reward
I actually got.
I run a trial, one trial.
Even if it's noisy with
my perturb parameters,
I change my parameters
a little bit.
I run a trial.
And what I want
to efficiently do
is compare it to the reward I
should have expected to get,
given I had the parameters
I had a minute ago.
Right?
That's nothing but a
value function right here.
OK?
So the simplest way to think
about an actor critic algorithm
is go ahead and use a TD
learning kind of algorithm.
Every time I'm running
my robot, go ahead
and work on in the
background learning
a value function of the system.
And simply use that to
compare the samples you
get from your policy search.
Do you guys remember the sort
of weight perturbation type
updates enough for
that to make sense?
Yeah?
STUDENT: So in this case, that
[INAUDIBLE] into your system
but just through
some expectation.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Excellent.
That's where you're getting it.
From temporal
difference learning.
In the case of a stochastic
system, where both of these
are going to be noisy
random variables,
this actually can be better
than running it twice.
Because this is the
expected value accumulated
through experience.
Right?
And that's what you really want
to compare your noisy sample
to the expected value.
So in the stochastic
case, you actually
do better by comparing it to the
expected value of your update.
What you can show
by various tools
is that comparing to the
expected value of your update,
which is the value
function here,
can dramatically reduce the
variance of your estimator.
OK?
You should always think
about policy gradient
as every one of
these steps trying
to estimate the change
in the performance
based on a change in parameters.
But in general,
what you get back
is the true gradient
plus a bunch of noise,
because you're just taking
a random sample here
in one dimension of change.
If this is a good estimate
of the value function,
then it can reduce the
variance of that update.
Question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE: The
guarantees of convergence
are still intact because
you're doing gradient descent.
You can actually do, you
can do almost anything here.
This can be zero.
And gradient descent, the
policy gradient actually
still converges.
It doesn't converge very fast.
But you can still
actually show that it'll,
on average, converge.
OK?
So it's actually quite robust
to the thing you subtract out.
Because, especially if this
thing doesn't depend on alpha,
then it has zero expectation.
So it doesn't even affect the
expected value of your update.
So it actually does not affect
the convergence results at all.
So the convergence
results are still intact.
But the performance
should get better
because you have a better
estimate of your J. Right?
And that should be
intuitively obvious, actually.
Right?
If I did something and
I said, how did I do?
And [INAUDIBLE]
just always said,
you should have gotten a
four every single time.
If I got a lousy estimator of
how well I should have done,
I'd say, OK.
Look, I got a six that time.
And he says, you
should have had a four.
Six, you should have had a four.
Then he's giving
me no information.
And that's not helping
me evaluate my policy.
Right?
If someone said, OK.
We did something a
little different.
I expected you to get a
six, but you got a 6.1.
Well, that's a much cleaner
learning signal for me to use.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
the worst possible--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah, absolutely.
So that's the important
point is that it's
got to be uncorrelated with the
noise you add to your system.
OK?
If it's not correlated
with the noise you add in,
then it actually goes
away in expectation.
So the variance can be very bad
if you have the worst possible
value estimate.
But the convergence
still happens.
Like I said, zero
actually works.
Right?
Which is sort of surprising.
If I have a reward function
that always returns between zero
and 10, and I'm trying
to optimize my update,
then I would always move in the
direction of the noise I add.
But I move more often in the
ones that gave me high scores.
And actually, it still
does a gradient descent
on the cost function.
It's actually worth
thinking about that.
It's actually pretty cool that
it's so robust, that estimator.
But certainly with a good
estimator, it works better.
I don't know how
much John told you.
But we don't actually like
talking about the variance.
We like talking about the
signal to noise ratio.
Did you tell them about the
signal noise ratio, John?
STUDENT: I don't remember.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Quickly?
Yeah.
So John's got a nice paper.
Maybe he was being modest.
John has a nice paper
analyzing the performance
of these with a signal to
noise ratio analysis, which
is another way to look at the
performance of the update.
So that's enough to do, to take
the power of the value methods
and start putting them to use
in the policy gradient methods.
OK?
The cool thing is, like I said,
as long as it's uncorrelated
with z, it can be a very
bad approximate of the value
function.
It won't break convergence.
The better the value estimate,
the faster your convergence is.
OK?
This isn't the update
that people typically
use when they talk about
actor critic updates.
The Konda and Tsitsiklis one
has a slightly more beautiful
thing.
This is maybe what you think
of as an episodic update.
Right?
This is, I just said we
started initial condition x.
Maybe I should right
an x zero or something.
But we just start with
initial condition x.
We run our robot for a little
bit with these parameters.
We compare it to
what we expected.
And we make an update
maybe once per trial.
That's a perfectly
good algorithm
for making an update
once per trial.
There's a more beautiful
sort of online update.
Right?
If you actually want
to, let's say you
have an infinite horizon thing.
Infinite horizon problem.
There's actually a theorem,
I've debated how much of this
to go into.
But I'll at least list
the theorem for you
because it's nice.
They call it the policy
gradient theorem,
which says partial
J partial alpha,
where in the infinite
horizon case typically
there's different ways to
define infinite horizons.
This is typically done in
an average reward setting.
It can be made to work
for other formulations.
But I'll just be careful
to say the one that I
know it's a correct proof for.
The policy gradient can
actually be written as--
let me write it out.
This guy is the stationary
distribution of executing
of the state action, of
executing pi of alpha.
This guy is the Q function
executing alpha, the true Q
function.
And this is the state action.
And this guy is
actually the gradient
of the log
probabilities, which is
the same thing we saw in the
policy gradient algorithms.
The log probabilities
of executing pi.
Yeah.
Gradient of the log probability.
I'm not trying to give you
enough to completely get this.
But just I want you
to know that it exists
and know where to find it.
And what it reveals is
a very nice relationship
between the Q function
and the gradients
that we were already computing
in our reinforced type
algorithms.
OK?
And it turns out an
update of the form--
this is gradient of the
log probabilities again.
I'll just write it.
That would be doing
gradient descent on this
if you're running
from sample paths.
This term disappears if
I'm just pulling x and u
from the distribution
that happens
when I run the system that gives
me this stationary distribution
coefficient for free.
OK?
And then if I could
somehow multiply the true Q
function times my
eligibility-- this one,
I definitely have access to.
This one, I can only guess,
because I have access
to my policy.
I can compute that.
But this guy, I
have to estimate.
OK?
So if I put a hat on
there, then that's
actually a good estimator
of the policy gradient using
an approximate Q function.
And in the case where you hold
up your updates for a long time
and then make an estimate
in an episodic case,
it actually results in
that actual algorithm.
OK?
Getting to that from with
a more detailed explanation
is painful.
But it's good to know.
I think the way you're
going to appreciate
actor critic algorithms,
though, is by seeing them work.
OK?
So let me show you how I
made them work on a walking
robot for my thesis.
I've already done this.
Is it going to turn on?
Since I think everybody's
here, maybe we should do,
while it's booting, I'll
do a quick context switch.
Let's figure out
projects real quick.
And then we'll go back.
I don't want to run
out of time and forget
to say all the last
details about the projects.
Yeah?
Somehow, I never remember
to post the syllabus
with all the dates on there.
We're posting it now.
But I can't believe
I didn't post
a long time ago on the website.
But I hope you know that the
end of term is coming fast.
Yeah?
And you know you're
doing a write up.
Right?
And that write up,
we're going to say
that the 21st,
which is basically
the last day I can possibly
still grade them by,
the write up as described, which
is sort of I said six pages--
sort of an [INAUDIBLE]
type format--
is going to be due
on May 21 online.
OK.
But next week, last week
of term already, we're
going to try to do oral
presentations so you guys can
tell me--
eight minutes each is
what works out to be.
You get to tell us what
you've been working on.
OK?
For each project,
there are a few of you
that are working in pairs.
But we'll still just do
eight minutes per project.
And we have 19 total projects.
So I figure we do eight--
sorry, nine-- next Thursday,
which is going to be the 14th.
Is that right?
5-14.
And nine on 5-12,
working back here,
which leaves some unlucky son
of a gun going on Thursday.
And the way I've
always done this is I
have a MATLAB script here that
has everybody's name in it.
Yeah.
Why is it not on here?
OK.
I have a MATLAB script
with all your names in it.
OK?
And I'm going to do a
rand perm on the names.
And it'll print up
what day you're going.
STUDENT: Maybe in
fairness to that person,
would we all be happy
to stay an extra eight
minutes on whatever it is?
Tuesday?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Let's
do it this way first.
And then we'll figure it out.
[LAUGHTER]
And yes.
So I'm going to call
rand perm in MATLAB.
And for dramatic
effect this year,
I've added pause statements
between the print commands.
[LAUGHTER]
So we should have a good
time with this, I think.
I will, at least.
OK.
Good.
Let's make this nice and big.
I actually was going to
just use a few slides
from the middle of this.
But I thought I'd at least
let you see the motivation
behind it, which very well.
And I'll go through it quickly.
But just to see at least
my take on it in 2005,
which hasn't
changed a whole lot.
It's matured, I hope.
But I've told you
about walking robots.
We spent more time talking
about passive walkers
than we talked about some
of the other approaches.
But there's actually a lot of
good walking robots out there.
Even in 2005, there
were a lot of good ones.
This one is M2 from the Leg Lab.
The wiring could
have been cleaner.
But it's actually a
pretty beautiful robot
in a lot of ways.
The simulations of it are great.
It hasn't walked
very nicely yet.
But it's a detail.
[LAUGHTER]
Honda's ASIMO had sort of the
same sort of humble beginnings.
As you can imagine,
it's not really fair
that academics have to compete
with people like Honda.
Right?
I mean, so our robots
looked like what
you saw on the last page.
And ASIMO looks like
what it looks like.
But it's kind of fun to
see where ASIMO came from.
So this is ASIMO 0.000.
Right?
And this is actually
the progression
of their ASIMO robots.
That's the first one they
told the world about in '97.
Rocked the world of robotics.
I was in the Leg Lab, remember.
At the time, we were
kind of like, oh wow.
They did that?
Wow.
That sort of certain changes
our view of the world.
That's P3.
And that's ASIMO.
Right?
Really, really still one of the
most beautiful robots around.
You know about
under-actuated systems.
I don't have to tell you that.
You know about acrobots.
You know walking
is under-actuated.
Right?
Just to say it again--
and I said it quickly--
but essentially,
the way ASIMO works
is they are trying to
avoid under-actuation.
Right?
When you watch videos
of ASIMO walking,
it's always got its
foot flat on the ground.
There's an exception where it
runs with an [? arrow ?] phase
that you need a high
speed camera to see.
But--
[LAUGHTER]
It's true.
And that's just a
small sort of deviation
where they sort of turn off
the stability of the control
system for long enough.
And they can recover.
Their controller
is robust enough
in the flat on the
ground phase that they
can catch small
disturbances which
are their uncontrolled
aerial phase.
So for the most part, they keep
their foot flat on the ground.
They assume that their foot
is bolted to the ground, which
would make them fully actuated.
Right?
And then they do a lot
of work to make sure
that that assumption
stays valid.
So they're constantly estimating
the center of pressure
of that foot and trying to
keep it inside the foot, which
means the foot will not tip.
And this is if you've heard
of ZMP control, that's
the ZMP control idea.
OK?
And then they do good
robotics in between there.
They're designing desired
trajectories carefully.
They're keeping the knees
bent to avoid singularities.
They're doing some--
depends on the story.
I've heard good
claims that they do
very smart adaptive
trajectory tracking control.
I've heard more recently
that they just do PD control.
And that's good enough because
they've got these enormous gear
ratios.
And that's good enough.
OK.
So you've seen ASIMO working.
The problem with it is that
it's really inefficient.
Right?
Uses way too much energy.
Walks slowly.
And has no robustness.
Right?
I've told you that story.
Here's one view of everything
we've been doing in this class.
The fundamental thing
that ASIMO is not
doing in its control system
is thinking about the future.
OK?
So if you were taking a
reinforcement learning class,
you would have started off with
talking about delayed reward.
And that's what makes the
learning problem difficult.
Right?
I didn't use the words
delayed reward in this class.
But it's actually
exactly the same thing.
The fact that we're
optimizing a cost
function over some
interval into the future
means that I'm thinking
about the future.
I'm planning over the future.
I'm doing long term planning.
And if you think about having to
wait to the end of that future
to figure out if what
you did made sense,
that's the delayed
reward problem.
It's exactly the thing that
reinforcement learning folks
use to convince other people
that reinforcement learning is
hard.
OK?
So the problem in
walking is that you
could do better if you
stopped just trying to be
fully actuated all the time.
We start thinking
about the future.
Think about long term
stability instead
of trying to be fully actuated.
OK?
The hoppers, there are examples
of really dynamically dexterous
locomotion.
But there's not general
solutions to that.
That's what this class
has been trying to go for.
So we do optimal control.
We would love to have
analytical approximations
for optimal control for
full humanoids like ASIMO.
Love to have it.
Don't have it.
We're not even close.
You know the tools
that we have now.
But even if we did have an
analytical approximation
of optimal control-- maybe
we will in a few years,
who knows--
we'd still like
to have learning.
Right?
All this model free
stuff is still valuable
because, if the world
changes, you'd like to adapt.
Right?
So my thesis was
basically about trying
to show that I could
do online optimization
on a real system in real time.
And I told you about
Andrews Helicopters.
There's a lot of
work on Sony Dogs
that do loop trajectory
optimization from trial
and error.
So Sony came out.
And they had this
sort of walking gait.
Right?
And then people start
using them for soccer.
And they said, how fast
can we make this thing go?
It turns out the
fastest thing they
do on an IBO is to make it
walk on its knees like this.
And they found that from
a policy gradient search
where they basically made
the dog walk back and forth
between sort of a pink
cone and a blue cone,
just back and forth all day
long doing policy gradient.
And they figured out this
is a nice fast way to go.
And then they won the
soccer competition.
[LAUGHTER]
Not actually sure if
that last part is true.
I don't know who won.
But I'd like to think it's true.
There are people that do
a lot of walking robots.
I think I showed you the
UNH bipeds that were some
of the first learning bipeds.
Right?
I told you about these all term.
So there's large continuously
in action spaces,
complex dynamics.
We want to minimize
the number of trials.
The dynamics are
tough for walking.
Because of the collisions.
And there's this delayed reward.
So in my thesis,
the thing I did was
tried to build a robot
that learned well.
That was my goal.
I simultaneously designed
a good learning system
but also built a robot where
learning would work really
well.
Instead of working on ASIMO,
I worked on this little dinky
thing I call Toddler.
Yeah?
And I spent a lot of time
on that little robot.
So you know about
passive walking.
This is the simplest, this
is the first passive walker I
built. Passive walking 101 here.
So it's sort of a funny story.
I mean, I was in a
neuroscience lab.
I worked with the Leg Lab.
But my advisor was
in neuroscience.
They spent lots of money on
microscopes and lots of money.
So at some point, I said, can
I spend a little bit of money
on a machine shop?
And I promise it'll cost
less than that lens you just
spent on that one microscope?
And so, he gave me a little
bit of money to go down.
I was basically in a closet
at the end of the hall.
My tools looked like
things like this.
Like, I couldn't even afford
another piece of rubber
when I cut off a corner.
And that's actually a CD rack
that I got rid of somewhere.
And that's my little
wooden ramp that I
was using for passive walking.
But I built these
little passive walkers
with a little sureline CNC
mill that walked stably
in 3D down a small ramp.
Yeah?
I don't know why
it's playing badly.
So that was the first steps.
If we're going to do
walking, it's not hard.
Those feet are
actually CNC-ed out.
I spent a lot of
time on those feet.
They're a curvature that
was designed carefully
to get stability.
STUDENT: It's just a
simple [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
Just a pin joint.
That's a walking robot.
At the time, people had been
working on passive walkers
for a long time.
But nobody had sort of
done the obvious thing,
which is add a few motors
and make it walk on the flat.
Nobody had done it.
So that's what I set out
to do with the learning.
Turns out a few people did
it around the same time.
So we wrote a paper together.
But the basic story was we went
from this simple thing that
was passive to the
actuated version.
The hip joint here on this
robot is still passive.
OK?
Put actuators in at the ankle.
So we had a new degrees
of freedom with actuators
so that it could
push off the ground
but still keep its
mostly passive gait.
Actually, it's extruded
stock here stacked
with gyros and rate gyros
and all the kinds of sensors.
It's got a 700 megahertz
Pentium in its belly,
which kind of stung.
In retrospect, I couldn't make
very many efficiency arguments
about the robot because it's
carrying a computer the size
of a desktop at the time.
You know?
And so, there's five
batteries total on the system.
Right?
Those four are
powering the computer.
There's one little one in there
that's powering the motors.
And still those big
four drained like
50% faster than the other ones.
But it's computationally
powerful.
Right?
I actually ran a little
web server off there
just because I
thought it was funny.
[LAUGHTER]
And the arms look like I've
added degrees of freedom.
But actually,
they're mechanically
attached to the opposite leg.
So when I move this,
that bar across the front
was making that coupling
happen, which is
important for the 3D walking.
Because if you
want to walk down,
if you have no arms actually
and you swing a big heavy foot,
then you're going to
get a big yaw moment.
And the robots
often walk like this
and went off the
side of the ramp.
So you put the big batteries
on the side and then everything
walks straight.
And it's good.
So in total, there's
nine degrees of freedom
if you count all the things
that could possibly move.
And there's four motors
to do the controls.
So that's under-actuated.
Right?
We've got the robot dynamics.
Oops.
I've used a Mac now.
I used to use a Windows.
So apparently my u is now O hat.
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry.
That's actually tau.
OK.
So tau.
Yeah.
So I had most almost the
manipulator equations.
But I had to go through
this little hobby servo.
So it wasn't quite the
manipulator equation.
And the goal was to find a
control policy pi that was--
so it was already stable
down a small ramp.
And the way I formulated
the problem is I
wanted to take that
same limit cycle
that I could find
experimentally down a ramp
and make it so it worked
on whatever slope.
So make that return map
dynamics invariant to slope.
And to do that, you
need to add energy.
And you need to find
a control policy.
So my goal was to find this
pi, stabilize the limit cycle
solution that I saw downhill
to make it work on any slope.
So this was just showing that
Toddler, with its computer
turned off, its motors
are turned on-- actually,
this one is even
the motors are off.
And there's just little
splints on the ankle.
Just showing that it was
also a passive walker.
And showing that I dramatically
improved my hardware experience
by getting a little
proform treadmill
that was off of the back lot.
And I painted it
yellow and stuff.
So this thing would
actually walk all day long.
It would.
So it's a little trick.
At the very edge, in the middle,
there's nothing going on.
But at the very edge
of the treadmill,
I put a little lip there.
So if it happened to wander
itself over to the side,
it had that lip and walked
back towards the middle.
OK?
And I put a little wedge on
the front and on the back
so it sort of would try to stay
in the middle of the treadmill.
And that thing would
just walk all day long.
It would drive you crazy hearing
those footsteps all day long.
[LAUGHTER]
But it worked.
It worked well.
It still works today,
most of the time.
So I use the words
policy gradient.
But this was really an
actor critic algorithm.
So I used linear, it's actually
a very centric grid in phi.
But a linear function
approximator.
And the basic story
was policy gradient.
OK?
So it was something in
between this perfectly online
at every dt, make an update.
And it was not quite the
episodic run a trial,
stop, run a trial, stop.
The cost function was
really a long term cost.
But I did it once per footstep.
OK?
So every time the robot
literally took a footstep,
I would make a small change
to the policy parameters.
See how well it walked.
See where it hit the return map.
And then change the
parameters again.
Change the parameters again.
And every time that
foot hit the ground,
I would evaluate the change
in walking performance
and make the change in W
based on that result. OK.
I'll show you the algorithm
that I used a second, which
you'll now recognize.
So the way to think
about that sampling in W
is that you're estimating
the policy gradient.
And you're performing online
stochastic gradient descent.
Right?
So the time, the way I
described the big challenge
is, what is the cost
function for walking?
And how do you achieve
fast provable convergence,
despite noisy
gradient estimates?
You guys know about return maps.
This is my picture of return
maps from a long time ago.
So this is the Van
der Pol Oscillator.
This is the return map here.
The important point
here, so this is
the samples on the return map.
This is the velocity at the n-th
crossing versus the velocity
at the n-th plus 1 crossing.
The blue line is the
line of slope one.
So it's stable, the
Van der Pol Oscillator,
because it's above the line
here and below the line there.
And you can evaluate
local stability
by linearizing and
taking the eigenvalues.
We've talked about these things.
But I don't know if I made
the point nicely before.
That if you can pick anything,
if you want your return
map to look like
anything in the world,
if you could pick,
what would you pick?
You'd pick a flat line.
Right?
That's the deadbeat controller.
I used the word deadbeat.
So that's where my cost
function came from.
The cost function that tried to
say that the robot was walking
well--
wow-- penalized my
instantaneous cost
function, penalized the square
distance between my sample
on the return map and
the desired return map,
which is that green line.
OK.
So basically I wanted, I
tried to drive the system
to have a deadbeat controller.
And I did, and there's limits.
There's actuator limits
that's going to mean
it's never going to get there.
But my cost function was
trying to force that.
Every time I got
a sample, it was
trying to push that
sample more towards
the deadbeat controller.
Then basically, it worked.
It worked really well.
The robot began walking
in one minute, which
means it started getting
its foot cleared.
So the first thing, if
I set W equal to zero,
it was configured so that when
the policy parameters were
zero, it was a passive walker.
So I put it on flat.
I picked it up.
I picked it up a lot.
And I drop it.
It runs out of energy
and stands still.
Because it was just
a passive walker,
it's not getting energy from--
it's only losing energy.
OK?
So now, I pick it up.
I drop it.
And every time it takes a step,
it's twiddling the parameters
at the ankle a little bit.
OK?
So it started going
like this a little bit.
And then after about a minute
of dropping it-- and quickly,
I wrote a script that would
kick it into place so I stopped
dropping it--
OK.
So I gave a little script
so it would go like this.
And in about one minute, it
was sort of marching in place.
OK?
And then I started
driving it around.
I had a little
joystick which said,
I want your desired
body to go like this.
And it started walking around.
And in about five minutes, it
was sort of walking around.
I'll show you the
video here in a second.
And then, I said 20
minutes for convergence.
That was conservative.
Most of the time,
it was 10 minutes.
It would converge to the
policy that was locally optimal
in this policy class.
But it worked very well.
And I just sort of sent
it off down the hall.
And it would walk.
OK?
And doing the
stability analysis,
it showed the learn controllers
is considerably more stable
than the controllers I
designed by hand, which I spent
a long time on those, too.
And now, here's a
really key point.
OK?
So you might ask, how much is
this sort of approximate value
function, how important is that?
That's sort of the
topic for today.
Right?
How important is this
approximate value function?
Well, it turns out, if I
were to reset the policy,
if I just set the policy
parameters to zero again
but keep the value function
from the previous time
it learned, then the whole
thing speeds up dramatically.
So instead of converging
in 20 minutes,
the thing converges
in like two minutes.
OK?
So just by virtue of having
a good value estimate there,
learning goes
dramatically faster.
And it's only when
I have to learn them
both simultaneously
that it takes more
like 10 or 20 minutes.
And it worked so fast that
I never built a robot.
I never built a
model for the robot.
Actually, I tried later.
It's tough.
The dynamics of that--
I mean, it's a curved foot
with rubber on it, right?
It was just very hard
to model accurately.
And I didn't need to.
It worked.
It learned very quickly.
Quickly enough that it was
adapting to the terrain
as it walked.
All right.
So here's the Poincar maps
from that little Toddler robot
projected onto a plane.
So I picked it up
a bunch of times.
I tried to make it just
walk in place here.
Before learning,
it was obviously
only stable at the
zero, zero fix point.
It was running out of energy on
every step and going to zero.
After learning, this is what
the return map looked like.
OK?
So it actually could start
from stopped reliably.
Right?
This is actually far better
than I expected it to do.
If you do your little
staircase analysis of this,
so it gets up to the fixed point
in two steps or three steps
for most initial conditions.
Right?
And from a very large range
of initial conditions,
as large as I care
to sample from.
So you could go up there--
and people did actually.
We had a little--
after we got it
working, the press came.
And then everybody was asking
me, the reporters were saying,
can I have my kid
play with the robot?
Or can we put on a
treadmill at the gym?
Rich Sutton put his
fingers under it
and was like playing
with it at dips one time.
So it got disturbed
in every possible way.
And for the most part,
it worked really--
I mean, so if you give
it a big push this way,
it actually takes energy out
and comes back and recovers
in two steps.
You stop it.
It goes back up.
And it recovers.
And in the worst case, I had
some demo to give or something.
And I took it out of the case.
It had traveled
through the airport.
The customs people always asked
me if it had commercial value.
It doesn't have
commercial value.
But it broke somewhere
in the travel.
And I didn't realize it.
I picked it up and
headed to do its demo.
And it's going like this.
And it's sort of walking.
And it looks a little funny.
And people are so
relatively happy with it.
Turns out the ankle
had completely snapped.
But in just a few
steps, it actually
found a policy that was
walking with a broken ankle.
[LAUGHTER]
So it works.
It really worked.
It really did work.
I'm not sure-- I mean, yeah.
It really worked.
OK.
So here's the basic video.
This was the beginning.
I was paranoid.
So I had pads on it to make sure
it didn't fall down and break.
This is the little policy
that would kick it up
into a random initial
condition like that.
And now it's learning.
It falls down.
I don't know why it's
playing so badly.
This is after a few minutes.
It's stepping in place.
It's walking.
And then I started
driving it around.
I say, OK.
Let's walk around.
And it stumbles.
But really, really fast,
it learned a policy
that could stabilize it.
Right?
And after a few minutes, this
is the disturbance tests.
I actually haven't shown
these in a long time.
It's really robust
to those things.
And then you can send
it off down the hall.
And now, this is a little
robot with big feet admittedly.
But you know, it's like
the linoleum in E25--
this is in E25--
was really not flat.
I mean, it's sort of
embarrassing to tell people,
look at the floor.
It's not flat.
But for that robot, I mean
there's huge disturbances
as it walked down the floor.
But the policy parameters
were changing quite a bit.
You could walk off
tile onto carpet.
And in a few steps, it
would adjust its parameters
and keep on walking.
This was it walking from
E25 towards the Media Lab,
if you recognize that.
OK.
So one of the things
I said is that one
of the problems with
the value estimate
is you make a small change
in the value function,
you get a big change
in the policy.
Theoretically, no problem.
In practice, you don't
probably want that.
Right?
One of the beautiful things
about the policy gradient
algorithms is you make a
small change to the policy.
It doesn't look like the
robot's doing crazy things.
So every time,
everything you saw there,
it was always learning.
Right?
Learning did not look
like a big deviation
from nominal behavior.
I never turned off
learning with this.
Right?
It turned out in the
policy gradient setting,
I could add such a
small amount of noise
to the policy parameters,
which was a very central grid
over the state space, such
a small amount of noise
that you couldn't even
tell it was learning.
Right?
But it was enough to pull
out a gradient estimate
and keep going.
So it didn't look like it
was trying random things.
But then, if it walked off on
the carpet and did a bad thing,
it would still adapt.
That was something
I didn't expect.
It just was a very
nice sort of match
between the amount of
noise you had to add
and the speed of learning.
The value estimate was a low
dimensional approximation
of the value function.
Very low.
Like ridiculously low.
One dimension.
Right?
But it was sufficient
to decrease the variance
and allow fast convergence.
I never got it to work before
I put a value function in.
And here's this question.
So I ended up choosing
gamma to be pretty low.
Gamma was 0.2.
I did try with zero times.
What did that mean?
So that's how far I carried
back my eligibility, which
means how many steps
am I looking at it.
So that you could think of it
as a receding horizon optimal
control.
How many steps
ahead do you look?
Right.
Except it's discounted.
OK?
So 0.2 is really
heavy discounted.
Really, really heavy.
It means I was basically
looking one step ahead
and not worrying
about things well
into the future, which made
my learning faster but meant
I didn't take really aggressive
corrections that were
multi-step sort of corrections.
Only very rarely, if the
cost really warranted it.
OK.
So that was always
something I thought
would be cool if I
could get that higher
and show a reason why
multi-step corrections made
it a lot more stable.
STUDENT: Did it
not work as well?
RUSS TEDRAKE: It
didn't learn as fast.
At some point, I
decided I'm going
to try to make the point
that these things can really
learn fast.
And so, I started
turning all the knobs.
Simple policy, simple value
function, low look ahead.
And it worked.
But it was fast.
STUDENT: Is gamma used
[INAUDIBLE] the same as lambda?
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's a gamma in a
discounted reward formulation.
STUDENT: So there is
no eligibility trace?
RUSS TEDRAKE: The
eligibility trace
for the reinforce in
a discounted problem
is the same as the
discount factor.
So in my lab now,
we're doing a lot
of these model based things.
We're doing LQR trees.
We're doing a lot of things.
In fact, the linear
controls are working
so beautifully in simulation
that Rick Corey, one
of our guys, started joshing me.
He's like, why didn't you
just do LQR on Toddler?
And he was giving me a
hard time for a long time.
Now he's asking about
model free methods
again because it's really hard
to get a good model of very
underactuated systems.
I mean, the plane that I'll
tell you about more on Thursday,
our perching plane we've seen
quickly, is one actuator.
And depending on how
you count the elevator,
eight degrees of
freedom roughly.
And sorry, eight
state variables.
And it's just very, very
hard to build a good model
for that that's accurate for the
long trajectory, the trajectory
all the way to the perch
such that LQR could just
stabilize it.
We're trying.
But there's something sort of
beautiful about these things
that just work without
building a perfect model.
OK?
The big picture is
roughly the class you saw.
This is actually, I had
forgotten about this.
This was one of my backup
slides from before.
But this is the basic
learning plot, which
is just one average run here.
If I reset the
learning parameters,
how quickly would it minimize
the average one step error?
And it was pretty fast.
And then actually,
that's a lot of steps.
That's more than I remember.
But this takes
steps once a second.
And so, in a handful of minutes,
it does hundreds of steps.
OK.
And this is the policy in two
dimensions that it learned.
So if you think about a theta
role and theta role dot,
I don't know if you have
intuition about this,
but the sort of yin
and yang of the Toddler
was that you wanted to push when
you're in this side of the face
portrait and push
with this foot when
you're on this side
of the face portrait.
I did things like I
mirrored, the left ankle
was doing the inverse, the
mirror of the right ankle.
Right?
So everything I could do
to try to minimize the size
of the function I was learning.
And that's actually sort
of a beautiful picture
of how it needed to push in
order to stabilize and skate.
Any questions about that?
All right.
So that's one success story
from model free learning
on real robots.
It learns in a few minutes.
There's other success stories.
I'll try to talk about
more of them on Thursday.
But at this point,
I've basically
given you all the tools that
we talk about in research
to make these robots tick.
Their state estimation,
I didn't talk about.
There's Morse's idea that
we didn't talk about.
But this is, I've given
you a pretty big swath
of algorithms here.
So really I want to now
hear from you next week.
And I want to give
you a few more case
studies so you feel that
these things actually
work in practice.
And you can go off and you
use them in your research.
Yeah, John?
STUDENT: If there is a lot of
stuff that's been published
and a lot of interest
[INAUDIBLE] stochasticity,
then it would make sense to
have a large gamma [INAUDIBLE]..
Right?
There'd be no
reason, it would be
a faulty way of trying
to interpret that data.
Right?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
I mean, I think that so Katie's
stuff, the metastability stuff,
argued that for most of
these walking systems,
it doesn't make sense to look
very far in the future anyways.
Because the dynamics
of the system
mix with the stochasticity,
which I think is the same thing
you just said.
Yeah.
STUDENT: The general dimensions
of the robot [INAUDIBLE]
when you're
designing that robot,
thinking about this model free
learning when you started?
[INAUDIBLE] helps it be
a little more stable.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
So I'm glad you asked that.
So it's definitely
very stable, which
was experimentally convenient.
Right?
Because I didn't have
to pick it up as much.
But it actually learns fine
when it starts off unstable.
So the way I tested that is, if
the ramp was very steep, then
it starts oscillating
and falls off sideways.
So just to show that it can
stabilize and unstabilize.
It's like, oh, the
same cost function.
It's absolutely no different.
I showed that it
stabilized that.
And it just meant
I had to pick it up
when it fell down
a bunch of times.
But the same algorithm
works for that.
So it's not really the stability
that I was counting on.
That was just
experimentally nice.
The big clown feet
and everything
were because that's how I knew
how to tune the passive gait.
Right?
In the passive walkers
we work on these days,
you always see point feet.
Because I care about
rough terrain now.
And those clown feet are
not good for rough terrain.
So we could try to
get rid of that.
STUDENT: You're saying if you
wanted to scale that out, you
had mentioned the [INAUDIBLE]
robots [INAUDIBLE] would
you have the same
success [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: Got you.
I think it's fine.
I think that it would look
ridiculous that big maybe.
And I wouldn't scale
the feet quite that big.
Right?
That would be ridiculous.
But I don't think there's any
scaling issues there really.
It's the inertia of the
relative links that matters.
And I think you can
scale that properly.
At some point
you're going to just
look ridiculous if you don't
have knees and you're that big.
So yeah.
Energetically, the
mechanical cost of transport,
if you just look at the power
coming out of the batteries--
sorry, actually the work
done by the actuators,
the actual work done
by the actuators.
It was comparable to a human,
20 times better than ASIMO.
But if you plot the current
coming out of the batteries,
it was three times worse than
ASIMO or something like that.
Because it's got these little
itty bitty steps and really
big computer.
And that was, in retrospect,
maybe not the best decision.
Although I never had to
worry about computation.
I never had to
optimize my algorithms
to run on a small embedded chip.
STUDENT: Can you talk a little
bit about the [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: You can
actually see it here.
So this is the
barycentric policy space
that were the parameters.
Yeah.
So it was tiled over
0.5, 0.5 roughly.
And you could see the
density of the tiling there.
Yeah.
And that was trained.
So there was no generalization.
So the fact that those looked
like sort of consistent blobs
was just from experience
and eligibility traces
carrying through.
But those are not constrained
by the function approximator
to be similar more
than one block away.
There's literally a
barycentric grid there.
And then the value estimate
was theta equals zero.
The different theta dots.
It was just the same size tiles.
But a line just
straight up the middle.
STUDENT: So your joystick
would just change theta?
Or not the theta?
But it would just
change the position.
RUSS TEDRAKE: The joystick
was, so the policy was mostly
for the side to side angles,
which would give me limit cycle
stability.
And then I could just
joystick control the front
to back angles.
So this thing, we could
just lean it forward.
It starts walking forward.
Even uphill.
That's fine.
You lean back, it
starts walking back.
It was really basically this.
Yeah.
If you want it to turn,
you've got to go like this.
And it would do its thing.
Right?
So that was it.
It wasn't sort of
highly maneuverable.
Yeah.
STUDENT: It seems like there
are some [INAUDIBLE] to step
to step, having
each step be like--
RUSS TEDRAKE: A trial.
STUDENT: So a section
on your Poincar map.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
STUDENT: I don't know if
that would work for flapping.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Absolutely.
STUDENT: If
[INAUDIBLE] up or down
is a similar kind of thing.
RUSS TEDRAKE: I think it would.
We were thinking
about it that way.
So you're absolutely right.
So it was nice to
be able to, it was
very important to
be able to add noise
by sort of making a persistent
change in my policy.
So this whole
function, adding noise
meant this whole function
would change a little bit.
And then I would stay
constant for that whole run.
And then change a little bit.
If you add noise every
DT, for instance, then you
have to worry about it filtering
out with motors and stuff.
This was actually a very
convenient discretization
in time on the point grade map.
Yeah.
So I think that was one
of the keys to success.
John?
STUDENT: The actuators you
took, were they pushing off
the sort of stance foot?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Or
pulling it back up.
But yes.
STUDENT: So you just
actuated the stance foot.
That was the
actuator [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: The units were,
I guess they were scaled out.
I did actually do the
kinematics of the link.
So it was literally
a linear command in--
those are probably meters
or something in the--
no.
It's way too big.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STUDENT: Touching down, but
touch down at the same angle?
RUSS TEDRAKE: No.
The swing foot was
also being controlled.
So it would get a
big penalty actually
if it was at a weird angle
when it touched down.
It would hit and it would
lose all its energy.
But that was free to
make that mistake.
STUDENT: So you have
two actions then?
The address to [INAUDIBLE]?
RUSS TEDRAKE: No.
Well, it's one action.
But the policy is being run
on two different actuators
at the same time.
So one of them is over in
this side of the state space.
And the other one's over
in the side of the state
space at the same time.
STUDENT: OK.
So it just used different data.
But they're-- OK.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
So just it was learning
on both of those sides
at the same time.
I'm a big fan of simplicity.
It's easy to make
things that work.
I mean, I think it's a good
way to get things working.
So that's what the test
will be as we go forward
in how complex we can
make these things.
But in sort of the simple
case, they work really well.
Great.
OK.
So thanks for putting up with
the randomized algorithm.
We'll see you on Thursday.